do you think that nate diaz fight is
just like uh do you think he's going to
care about it is that impossible for him
not to care about it versus hum
yeah i mean he has to care about it
hamzad is a [ __ ] assassin hamzad is a
terrifying human being he's terrifying
he's really oh really good and really
big
i get scared at home you should be yeah
i mean that's how it is yeah hamza is a
murderer i mean when he when he gets
into that octagon he's seek and destroy
he's a dangerous man
do you think that it's just a setup
fight for not like it's like because i
know he's trying to get out of his
contract do you think that or do you
think he'd ask for that fight oh he did
that's what that nate wanted to fight
francis and ganu oh damn
nate is his game as a human being has
ever been
that dude is wild i mean that's one of
the things that dana white said they
were like saying why did you do this
fight it's like that's the fight nate
wanted he goes by the way nate asked for
francis and ghana damn
that'd have been awesome but no yeah
you're right no i mean but you know what
there would have been something exciting
about it yeah murder
yeah
something exciting when francis and gano
a natural 270 pound man who hits harder
than any human being that's ever been
recorded
this is the hardest punch ever recorded
well francis is terrifying i think they
could take him dude do you think so i
don't know i don't i mean i haven't i
don't i don't know nate just never ends
bro he hope you're never a bookmaker
yeah that's true
i hope so there's certain things that
you just ca there's certain
physical attributes and advantages you
cannot overcome it's not saying that
nate isn't a an amazing fighter nate is
an amazing fighter and has been for a
long time i mean you can go way back
nate has been submitting and beating
people for a long [ __ ] time he's a
tough [ __ ] yeah but francis is
gigantic he's gigantic
francis is gigantic
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one